what do you think about The long-running
Saga of Israel and Palestine will we
ever see peace in that part of the
Middle East well since I'm an optimist
about human
um
look I I mean I have many many thoughts
about I'm a very very strong supporter
of Israel uh and uh and I also feel
really for the plight of the
Palestinians I think that they're
you know this is uh
this is a a clash of legitimate
narratives that is impossible to exactly
split the difference of
however
um
I know that Israel has made peace with
Egypt has made peace with Jordan has
made peace now with other Arab Nations
uh I don't believe that Israel is
unwilling to make peace
and so I think that as difficult as it
will be
for the Palestinians to come to grips
with the fact that the Jewish state is
not leaving and is legitimately here as
opposed to we can't get rid of it now
but we will get rid of it one day
if that
comes to be and I believe that it will I
think not only that there would be peace
but I think that those two peoples
together could probably do remarkable
things in the world
do you think the source of it is
politics is it religious ideas and
to flip it what is the way out is it
geopolitics is it uh you know Interfaith
discourse and collaboration or is it
simply the human
uh like love so I think that I'm not
sure that I could give one answer to
that but I will give a piece of an
answer
why did the Abraham Accords happen
the main reason that they happened was
because economics overrode ideology
and I actually am hopeful that that's in
the end what will happen
that people will say you know what we
could have such a better life
if we put aside the ideological
animosities and just created this
different kind of Middle East together
I went to Dubai
to watch the World Chess Championship
because I really wanted to see Magnus
Carlson play I thought you're alive when
when you have such a remarkable world
champion go see him play so I actually
took myself to Dubai that's amazing for
the last couple of games and I watched I
and so I wasn't so much I I mean it's
not that I'm uninterested in Dubai but I
really I went there for the chess thing
the Expo was also on at the same time
and I saw here's this amazing place I
came back this guy I know who lived in
Dubai for several years and works in the
Middle East said to me what did you
think of it and I said you know this
this is Dubai it was like very you know
very polished very sophisticated very
clean very no crime and so on but it was
like you know kind of like Las Vegas in
the Middle East without the gambling or
something like that he said you know
and he totally changed my perspective in
in a couple sentences he said I know it
seems like that when you come from Los
Angeles
he said but fly there from Yemen or from
Riyadh and it is a miracle and I thought
oh my God you're right
it's like what human beings can do if
they just put aside
their ideological shackles is remarkable
and I'm hopeful that one day that'll
happen economics allows for higher
quality of life you no longer it's the
playground analogy you said earlier if
there's more resources to play with
right unfortunately us humans are more
willing to play with others yeah and
maybe that is the solution and maybe I
mean for me from a technology
perspective Innovation engineering
helps make everybody's life better and
over over that once people's lives
become better they start to be
um have more time to be empathetic and
here and they have more to lose
when you have more to lose it actually
makes you I think
um countries are less willing to go to
war when they have more to lose and P
and and families want peace when they
have when when it's good at home so I
think there's an element of that as well
and some of it again taking us back to
the other aspect of our conversation is
how we're conducting ourselves in
conversation online and so on because I
think actually
I'm a big fan of the idea of social
media that is a way for us to connect uh
together I think there's a lot of really
strong ideas how to do that well
and clearly the initial attempts that
kind of just
um open it up wide some of the Lesser
aspects of human nature can take over
when combined with different forces like
advertisements and virology and all
those kinds of things but overall
I love the honesty of the mess of it
being presented before us on social
media I I part of me
maybe because I don't participate it
like if somebody is being mean to me or
being aggressive and these kinds of
things I enjoy it because it's it's
human nature right but I enjoy it
because I don't respond I think if I
responded I would get pulled into this
human nature and then it's not fun but I
I love the emo like I'll I'll talk to
people in fact I still visit Clubhouse I
don't know if you know what that is sure
oh right that's right actually when I I
was how we first met well yeah well I
was such a fanboy I actually when I
first heard you and uh I was like I
can't believe I guess
dude but uh the Israel Palestine
um topic was something that was very
deeply in a heated way uh discussed on
clubhouse race relations is a thing that
was really heatedly discussed and I now
go to clubhouse to practice Russian and
there in Russian the heated discussion
is on basically any topic as meaningless
or meaningful as you want In the Heat of
it just people just screaming and and
then calming down and going through the
full process and that that too is
beautiful because that emotion is there
and if it is allowed to have a voice I
think ultimately it's it leads to
Healing
um so that that felt really healthy if
you learn how to do that at scale social
media I I wish that it were not as
algorithmically biased towards conflict
um I don't think that that's healthy but
I do I I think it brings a lot of
blessings into people's lives if they
use it wisely you know it can like
anything else it can be awful
um but but it can't I I've connected to
all sorts of people that I never would
have known
um and that's been wonderful